good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 868 object class
Euclid noon T special containment
procedures two d-class personnel
infected with SCP 868 are to be
maintained in a soundproof humanoid
containment cell supervised by at least
one armed gon personnel wishing to
experiment with SCP 868 must submit to
an interrogation and background check to
confirm their loyalty to the foundation
and its methods all persons suspected of
hosting SCP 868 along with all persons
living in a community where an infecting
has been located are to be tested for
infection any subject found to be a
victim of a cpa at 68 must be treated
with a mn8 68 should a population
treated with a mn8 68 exhibit a
noticeable amount of unusual behavior a
follow-up amnestic should be distributed
any reports of scp-1850 cracy personnel
spreading a cp8 68 intentionally or
attempting to access the current carrier
of scp-1863-a
are to be court-martialed if applicable
and stripped of all security clearance
other ones description SCP 868 is a meme
that resulted from a memory improvement
therapy designed by Prometheus Labs
incorporated surviving documents
indicate that the researchers
responsible for creating SCP 868 were
unaware of its memetic properties until
shortly before the facility was
destroyed the process and materials
necessary for administering this
treatment have not been recovered
although recovered materials do not
indicate that its creation required
anomalous items
as CP 868 transfer mechanism is poorly
understood however it is believed to be
transferred by a two-way verbal
communication with an infected subject
for no less than thirty minutes with
symptoms manifesting between four and
nine days after infection stage once
symptoms typically include a
significantly improved short-term memory
with subjects typically being able to
clearly remember events and information
for eighty percent longer than they
would otherwise
on average subjects also report the
ability to recall events that happened
after initial infection with greater
accuracy than they would otherwise this
has been confirmed by testing the
effects of scp-1863-a
stage 2 Effects of scp-1863-a fection
prior to this subjects are frequently
able to remember with near perfect
accuracy any event or information
received after contracting SCP 868 and
from several days before however over
the course of between one and five days
directly proportional to the subjects
age this effect extends to encompass the
subjects entire lifespan
SCP 868 poses a significant risk to
foundation interests
due to its interaction with subjects
that have been affected by amnestics
testing has shown that hosting SCP 868
for any amount of time is sufficient to
prevent amnestics from affecting its
memories in addition during the second
stage of the infection SCP 868
completely negates the effects of any
amnestic administered at any point in
the subjects life potentially allowing
the subject to remember sensitive or
dangerous information this has held true
for all tested methods of inducing
amnesia both natural and man-made see
addendum 868 - prior to its full
containment SCP 868 caused five secrecy
breaches necessitating the termination
of individuals to prevent the spread of
sensitive information regarding the
foundation SCP objects and other
classified data subsequent cleanup and
cover-ups have cost an additional
containment breaches after its
containment have required additional to
contain addendum 868 one in June 19th
doctor's Carson and basak received
access to SCP 868 after filing the
relevant paperwork approximately six
weeks later reports from Bangladesh
indicated that residents had become
aware of the existence of SCP which had
been recovered from that location three
years previously investigation revealed
that the village and some outlying areas
had been infected with SCP 868 because
a.m. and 868 had not been created at
this point it was necessary to
neutralize the village under the
pretence of a flood under interrogation
both personnel admitted to releasing SCP
868 C incident report 868 seven for
details
addendum 868 2 in November 2008
foundation researchers developed a class
b3 amnestic amn 868 that was capable of
reversing the effects of scp-1863-a
infection in 70% of cases AMNH 68 will
only cause mild side effects
specifically severe headaches with an
estimated 10% of those at risk of
developing early onset Alzheimer's
disease in the remaining 30% a mn8 68
will function but will also cause
self-destructive tendencies and
prolonged antisocial behavior see for
details you know it's it's weird I've
never really thought about this before
but the cell block that SCP 868 D class
are contained I've never been allowed in
there or on that floor in fact I mean
should be nothing wrong with allowing me
up there right I can remember something
about Prometheus Labs but you know what
I probably read it somewhere before
maybe it's just my imagination this was
a very short lecture today everyone but
this is where it ends thank you very
much for listening and you were all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Pierce emmalin Muslim Mookie slump
God dr. day John Porter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key mana moon a
my archive curator Nick Thai verbal OD
10 CH cheese whip I'm dips McGee thank
you all so much for your support I
really appreciate it if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well as at patreon.com forward slash the
vulcan thank you
you